I am back in the UK and I have a cold
I've lost my voice I sound a little bit
like Tom Waits so it is the 21st century
why can I not just take a pill and cure
this thing well first of all the pills
that we do have are antibiotics and they
don't work against colds you have seen
this poster in your doctor's office um
you need a vaccination and well it's
difficult to find a vaccination for the
common cold
for the same reason that once you've had
one cold your body is not automatically
immune against all others there are
hundreds of the buggers and they keep
mutating it's the same reason why you
have to have a flu shot every year oh
actually that's worse than that the
World Health Organization has to predict
months in advance which flu strains will
be popular this winter and then ramped
up vaccine production accordingly and
they've got natural selection against
them too if they release that vaccine
too early then the viruses that are able
to rapidly mutate again stit will be
successful and will spread instead the
common cold works in a similar way there
are hundreds of strains constantly
mutating and because it doesn't
generally kill people just cause some
discomfort there isn't the millions and
millions and millions in research funds
going towards getting rid of it so
instead we take pain killers and
anti-inflammatories and decongestants
and we we accept that we can win this
battle on our own even though we cannot
win the war because the enemy will go
away mutate and just come back a few
months later and that is something you
may not have known and now I am going to
stop talking